think about this Steve Jobs was in his  20s and teens when he started Bill Gates  Mark Cuban Kylie Jenner you taught any  entrepreneur that's out there today that  you know pretty well most of them  started young Jay-Z started young LeBron  James started young why is it that you  can't start young Steve Jobs did I did  Cuban did Bill Gates did all there's  thousands of entrepreneurs in fact the  list of billionaires in the country gets  younger every single year as do the  millionaires you want to know why  because of these things right here  technology your phone your iPad social  media allows people at any age to win  including pre-teen and teenagers